[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
dans 100 % Sénat pour un nouveau numéro
de 100 % Sénat aujourd'hui la rédaction
de Public Sénat vous propose de revivre
deux auditions de la commission
d'enquête sur le trafic de stupéfiants
les premiers échanges pour les sénateurs
avec le directeur général de la police
nationale Frédéric vaau je vous laisse
suivre cette audition je vous retrouve
tout de suite après pour lancer le débat
vous avez été directeur à Marseille vous
avez suivi toutes ces questions de
manière précise qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur l'évolution de ce
trafic et de
de la structure même de ce narcotrafic
qui nous inquiète
grandement bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs pour
dire que je suis accompagnie donc du
directeur national adjoint de la police
judiciaire Philippe chadr et de la
commissaire de police Charlotte hun qui
est ma conseillère judiciaire je ne vais
pas vous abreuver de chiffres à
l'occasion de cette première prise de
parole mais évidemment sur ces sujetsl
les données chiffrées sont sont
importantes mais au travers des réponses
aux questionnaires que vous nous avez
adressé et des demandes que vous avez
formulé de communication dans un certain
nombre de pièces je pense que vous aurez
l'occasion de prendre connaissance de de
ces chiffres ce que je voulais dire en
quelques mots en propos introductif
c'est que nous sommes face à une réalité
que nous partageons malheureusement un
peu partout à travers le monde qui est
euh la la progression continue et forte
de la production des des produits
stupéfiants dans le monde quelle que
soit la nature de ces produits que ça
soit le cannabis l'héroïne la cocaïne
les drogues de synthèse nous sommes dans
une phase de progression très très
importante avec des trafiquants qui
agissent dans une logique économique que
je pourrais qualifier de de capitaliste
et d'ultralibéral avec bien sûr une
volonté de prendre la maîtrise de tous
ces marchés et de les développer quoi
qu'il arrive donc nous sommes en France
en particulier mais en Europe
à nous subissons à la fois cette
augmentation de la production et les
facilité que procure aujourd'hui le le
libre échange pour alimenter ces trafics
je voulais très rapidement en trois
parties vous faire un un état des lieux
du du trafic de stupéfiants dans notre
pays vous faire un petit bilan aussi
rapide de la manière dont nous agissons
et nous sommes efficaces ou pas dans la
lutte contre ces trafics
et vous décrire la la stratégie et les
moyens qui sont déployés pour lutter
contre les trafic de sufant en rappelant
effectivement vous l'avez dit Monsieur
rapporteur que mon premier poste en PO
judiciaire C il y a très longtemps en
1984 j'étais chef de la bagade des stup
à la PG de Lille j'ai été aussi chef de
la division des stupéfions et du
proxinétisme à Marseille de 1995 à
1998 et en 2001 trop peu de temps j'ai
été chef de l'Office central pour la
répression du trafic illicite de
stupéfiant donc j'ai vu effectivement
l'évolution assez négative que
malheureusement nous constatons sur ce
sujet du du trafic de de
stupéfiant le trafic de stupéfiant c'est
le premier marché criminel au monde qui
procure 250000 Milard de dollars de de
revenus par an ce sont les chiffres de
l'ONUDC elle est non seulement la
conséquence d'une augmentation de
l'offre mais aussi d'une augmentation de
la demande c'est un paramètre que nous
devons de de prendre en compte d'après
l'INC les Français auraient dépensé en
2020 4,2 milliards d'euros pour
s'approvisionner en produits stupéant la
première des drogues qui est consommé
dans notre pays c'est le cannabis et si
la consommation reste globalement stable
elle représente 80 % de la consommation
de l'ensemble des drogues et concerne 5
millions de consommateurs de 11 à 64 ans
dont 1,2 millions sont des usagers
réguliers et près de 80000 des usagers
quotidiens comme vous le savez le
cannabis est essentiellement enfin la
résine est essentiellement produite au
Maroc mais nous n'avons pas de données
chiffré que nous pouvons réellement
prendre en considération sur les
quantités qui sont produit
et pour ce qui concerne l'herbe de
cannabis elle est produite à plus grande
échelle en Espagne cette résine de
cannabis est essentiellement acheminé
vers notre pays par le par le vecteur
routier depuis le le territoire espagnol
nous avons aussi pour ce qui concerne le
cannabis un phénomène de culture locale
qui se développe en
2000 22 ce qu'il faut noter c'est que 56
% des pieds de cannabis qui ont été
saisis dans notre pille ont été en
outreem
particulièrement en Polynésie et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie la cocaïne est le
second produit stupéfiant le plus
consommé dans notre pays avec près de
600000 personnes qui en ont consommé au
cours de l'année 2022 autrefois c'était
plutôt un produit stupéfiant
rare servait à à certaines catégories
sociales et on voit que d'orénavant la
cocaïne c'est malheureusement
démocratisée avec une hausse de la
consommation qui est portée par cette
augmentation de la production mondiale
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et qui la
rend forcément plus disponible sur le
marché français comme vous le savez les
zones de production sont localisées en
Amérique du Sud 2304 tonnes y ont été
produites en 2021 soit une augmentation
de plus de 16 % par rapport à à l'année
précédente on voit que cette dynamique
est en plus une dynamique à deux
chiffres la cocaïne est essentiellement
acheminée vers l'Union européenne par
les ports d'Europe du Nord notamment
Rotterdam et enverse mais les ports
français sont aussi dorénavant ciblés
tant en mécropole que dans la zone
antiguyane en 2022 75,4 % des saisis de
cocaïne ont porté sur le vecteur
maritime et le port du Havre a totalisé
78 % des quantités saisies dans dans les
ports
français si on a donc prioritairement
cet acheminement de la cocaïne par le
vecteur
commercial nous avons par le fret
maritime nous nous avons toujours le
support du trafic par les navires de de
plaisance à voile avec les Antill
françaises qui constitue une zone de
rebond particulièrement stratégique dans
le cette route de la cocaïne vers la
France et enfin on a un autre vecteur
qui
alimente le trafic de cocaïne vers notre
pays c'est celui qui est réalisé par
petite quantité qui qui emploie le
vecteur aérien et notamment celui au
départ de la guuillane mais on y on y
reviendra peut-être au travers des
questions on a mis en place un
dispositif pour le contrer dès le départ
pour ce qui est de l'héroïne la
consommation reste rare dans la
population générale et est plutôt stable
depuis les années
90 avec un taux d'impact sur les sur la
population qui reste extrêmement faible
donc c'est un produit stupéfiant qui est
produit essentiellement en Afghanistan
et qui estcheminé pour ce qui concerne
la France par plusieurs routes la
principale étant la route des Balcans
occidentaux via la via la Turquie et
l'Iran avant de pénétrer sur le
territoire national principalement dans
les régions Grand Est et auovagner en
Alpes elle est souvent stocké en
Belgique et aux Pays-Bas qui sont les
principaux marchés secondaires de
distribution en Europe en ce qui
concerne les drogues de synthèse on
malheureusement on observe un usage
grandissant de ces drogues de synthèse
avec une diff
diversification pardon de de ces de ces
produits qui se rajoute à la
consommation de de l'extasie qui est la
plus connue cette consommation là
concerne environ 400000 usagers dans
notre pays alors la la lutte contre ces
trafic de de ces produits qui sont
extrêmement dangereux et est
complexifié en raison de plusieurs
éléments d'abord parce qu'on assiste à
de la distribution à partir de de site
en Lig qui sont basé à l'étranger donc
difficilement euh
euh contrôlable euh l'absence
d'harmonisation juridique en ce qui
concerne le statut de ces drogues de
synthèse euh certains sont classés selon
les pays stupéfiants ou non et la
modification de rapide de leur
composition qui peut être initiée qui
donc peut bousculer la manière dont on
peut mettre en œuvre la répression euh
de leur usage ou de leur trafic euh ce
qu'il faut noter aussi c'est que nous
avons
euh le problème de ce que les
laboratoires clandestin de ces drogues
de
synthèse qui ont émergé sur le sol
européen au Pays-Bas en Belgique en
Pologne ou en République tchèque
évidemment sont encore au plus près des
zones de consommation facilitant
facilitant C ces
trafic le
point que je note aussi c'est que
malheureusement les services en charge
de de la répression de ce trafic sont
confronté à des formes très diversifiées
de de ces trafic et notamment
vis-à-vis des organisations ou des
groupes qui s'adonnent à C trafic alors
évidemment on a toujours le système je
dirais assez classique de l'usager
revendeur qui procède à son petit niveau
à la revente de produits stupéfiants
pour permettre d'acheter sa propre
consommation personnelle mais ce que
nous constatons aujourd'hui c'est que le
marché de ces trafics de spéfiant et
surtout dominé par des groupes criminels
qui sont issus des quartiers
sensibles en effet en France le le
trafic de stupéfiant est principalement
tenu par des groupes criminels français
qui se structurent en général autour de
de membres qui qui partage ou des liens
géographiques ou des liens
communautaires ou des liens familiaux en
métropole je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ce
sont des plutôt des des personnes issues
des des quartiers dissensibles où
s'opère principalement de ces trafics et
donc on assiste mais comme vous le savez
hein je là-dessus je pense que je
n'apprends rien à personne une véritable
économie de quartier se structure autour
de ces trafic avec une main mise de ces
réseaux sur des zones territoriales très
identifiées qui est notamment la
conséquence et la traduction de
l'exploitation de vulnérabilité des
habitants en recrutant des guêteurs des
nourriss
ou même ou même des
vendeurs d'autres groupes sont aussi si
très actif autre que ces groupes
criminels implantés dans les dans les
quartiers ils sont ils le sont notamment
dans le trafic de cocaïne et ce sont
ceux qui sont issus de l'arc caribéen
aussi bien des Antill ou de la Guyane et
qui ont sur notre territoire hexagonal
des relais qui leur permettent de mettre
en place sur la base de filières
communautaires des réseaux extrêmement
structuré dans ce paysage criminel on a
aussi ce qu'on appelle des des cibles de
haute priorité qui sont en fait les
chefs les responsables et les
organisateurs de ces grands trafics qui
ne sont pas en général implantés sur
notre territoire qui agissent et qui
organisent ces trafics depuis l'étranger
avec certaines des places qui sont
particulièrement connu comme vous le
savez notamment à Dubaï mais mais pas
que on les voit aussi implantter dans
d'autres pays notamment notamment en
Afrique du Nord et qui agissent dans le
cadre d'alliance opportuniste avec
d'autres réseaux étrangers qui sont
particulièrement actifs sans doute le
plus connu tristement connu en Europe
étant celui de la mocromafia qui agit au
Pays-Bas et et en Belgique par ailleurs
on a des groupes criminels d'origine
étrangère je ne vais pas trop rentrer
dans les détails pour cette première
intervention mais on a des groupes
criminels d'origine albanaise qui sont
très implantés dans l'est de la France
et qui traditionnellement agissent dans
le domaine du trafic d'héroïnes mais qui
de ravant s'investissent a sur le trafic
de cocaïne on a aussi des réseaux
nigériens qui sont principalement
implantés dans la région marseillaise
mais qui
dorénavant élargissent leur champ
d'action un peu partout sur le
territoire national et qui s'implique
notamment dans le trafic de cocaïne
d'héroïne et
de
métamine voilà je difficile à prononcer
petit point aussi à souligner mais
peut-être je ne sais pas si vous
entendrez des représentants de la D RPJ
Paris évidemment le le trafic de trac
est un phénomène auquel nous accordons
la plus grande importance qui lui est
principalement tenu par des micro
réseaux d'origine
africaine liés aux filières
d'immigration illégale et même légale
d'ailleurs ainsi qu'aux filières de
cocaïne qui émanent de l'Afrique de de
l'Ouest ces réseaux d'orénavant mettent
en œuvre des moyens de distribution qui
sont diversifiés
évidemment comme je l'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure il y a il y a le deal de rue
principalement dans des quartiers dans
les quartiers qui euh qu'il tiennent en
faisant appel à une main d'œuvre locale
mais on voit émerger aussi d'autres
phénomènes qui consistent à faire appel
à une main-dœuvre qui n'est pas
originaire du quartier et qui est
recruté de différentes manières et pour
différentes raisons notamment le la
rémunération de de ces vendeurs ou de
sgetteur et la diminution de risqu selon
ces groupes criminels qui pourrai les
exposés si euh le le le fait qu'il soit
bien connu à à à ce que les ennemis s'en
prennent plus facilement à eux euh en
général ils sont recrutés pour de courte
durée quelques jours à quelques mois et
parfois dans des conditions extrêmement
violentes qui peuvent conduire à ce
qu'il soi séquestré et violentés pendant
de nombreux jours avant d'accepter de
prendre part à ces
trafic euh la question de la
rémunération de ces petites mains du
trafic est en général posée on a un peu
t tous les prix et tous les les tarifs
selon les les implantations de ces
trafics sur notre territoire on peut
trouver par exemple dans le département
Duin des
euh des emplois entre guillemets hein je
mets des guillemets rémunéré 30 € par
jour mais on a aussi sur les points de
Deal les plus structurés et les plus
rémunérateurs
des rémunérations qui peuvent aller de
50 € à 250 € la journée avec un
getteteur qui peut gagner jusqu'à 90 €
par jour et donc là-dessus la population
des jeunes déscolarisés des jeunes sans
emploi est évidemment très réceptive à à
ces solutions de proposé par par les
trafiquants parmi les les modes aussi de
distribution des produits stupéfiants on
a évidemment le recours nouvelles
technologie en particulier depuis la
crise sanitaire qui a été le moment où
les trafiquants au regard des
restrictions qui existaient ont dû faire
preuve d'imagination pour mettre en
place de nouveaux dispositif en
utilisant des applications sur
smartphone et les livraisons à domicile
évidemment ce que représente cet énorme
marché et euh la la masse d'argent qu'il
dégage fait augmenter sensiblement les
risques de corruption et les capacités
de de blanchiment qui sont nécessaires
pour replacer l'argent récolté dans une
forme de de circuit légale cette
capacité corruprice s'exerce
d'orénavant partout où le trafic peut
rencontrer des des obstacles à son
fonctionnement alors je pense notamment
aux ports et aux aéroports avec certains
certaines fonctions qui sont
particulièrement ciblées les dockers les
conducteurs de poids lourd les agents de
piste les bagagistes les membres du
personnel navigant et malheureusement
même aussi certains agents publics j'ai
quelques exemple assez triste en mémoire
et enfin pour ce qui concerne les le
blanchiment des sommes d'argent
considérables qui sont récolté comme je
l'ai indiqué évidemment il faut bien
trouver des moyens d'accéder au au
circuit de l'économie légale avec une
priorité pour les investissements dans
la restauration le BTP avec des systèmes
élaborés de transfert de fond tels
qu'ils peuvent exister aujourd'hui via
les cryptoonnaies par
exemple l'actualité nous le rappelle
trop souvent et encore ce weekend nous
assistons à une hausse des violences
liées à ces trafic de stupéfiants euh on
voit bien que c'est pour ces
organisations criminelles qui contrôlent
ces trafics un moyen d'assoir leur
emprise ou de l'augmenter en essayant de
de récupérer des marchés qui pourraient
être contrôlés par des équipes rivales
c'est aussi une méthode de représaille
qui malheureusement s'installe dans des
logique devant d'État dont on ne voit
jamais la fin entre groupes entre
groupes rivaux ça se manifeste à la fois
par des opération d'enlèvement de
séquestration de torture et des
homicides tentatives d'homicide
volontaire dont on peut malheureusement
constater qu'ell s'étendent au-delà des
villes qui les constaté régulièrement de
manière arcestrique
assez triste des villes des villes
moyennes de taille moyenne un peu
partout sur le territoire national j'ai
décidé de pas vous parler de vous donner
beaucoup de chiffres mais en ce qui
concerne ce phénomène je pense qu'il est
important d'être assez clair pour
montrer le niveau de gravité
exceptionnelle de ce qui se passe au 13
novembre 2023 nous avons constaté 315
homicides ou tentative d'homicide entre
malfaiteurs ce qui correspond à une
augmentation de 57 % par rapport à la
même période en
2022 parmi les 451 victimes recensées
puisque un fait peut provoquer plusieurs
malheureusement plusieurs victimes 30 %
on moins de 20
ans et on voit bien que dans certaines
villes je l'ai dit que ça soit à
Marseille à Nice à nî ces phénomènes là
aussi s'étendent au-delà de la
périphérie des villes dans les
centres-villes dans des logiques de
devant d'État comme je l'indiquais cette
diminution de l'âge des victimes se
retrouve aussi chez les auteurs où on
assiste quand ils sont interpellés
à un âge malheureusement très faible de
ceux qui qui se livrent à ces actes qui
sont sans doute la conséquence d'une
balinisation à la fois de l'accès aux
armes à feu et de l'usage qui peut qui
peut en être faite qui peut en être fait
malheureusement là aussi on a pu le
constater au cours du weekend avec des
victime collatéral comme ça s'est passé
donc à Dijon comme ça a pu se passer à
nîes ou comme ça a pu se passer à
Marseille donc ces phénomènes depuis
très
longtemps évidemment provoqu une forte
mobilisation des des services du
ministère de l'intérieur mais pas que la
direction générale des douanes est
évidemment très très mobilisée comme les
armées d'ailleurs la Marine nationale
est aussi elle très mobilisée pour ce
qui est de la police tous les services
il concourt je ne vais pas rentrer dans
les détails mais on a la direction
nationale de la sécurité publique
qui dispose de 1500 enquêteurs qui sont
spécifiquement dédiés à la lutte contre
le trafic de stupéfiant la direction
nationale de la police judiciaire aussi
bien au niveau central avec l'Office
qu'avec les antennes et les les
détachements de de l'ofast 24 anes
détachements partout sur le territoire
national et d'autres services qui à un
moment ou un autre apportent leur
concours à l'action de l'ofast au
travers des des infractions qui sont
périphériques à ces trafic de stupéfiant
je pense à à l'olclo euh à l'ocdf pour
le et la piaque pour le blanchiment
d'argent et donc pour la PJ en 2022 on
avait 1300 enquêteurs qui étit
spécifiquement euh dédié à la lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants je ne
voudrais pas oublier évidemment euh les
directions territorial de la police
nationale qui sont en Outremer avec en
particulier les antennes de l'ofast qui
sont implantées en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et en guyan mais pas que mais
c'est bien là qu'on a la stratégie du
bouclier entre les pays d'Amérique du
Sud et l'Europe la Direction de la
Coopération Internationale de de
sécurité avec ces officiers de liaison
spécialisé stupéfiant qui sont implantés
à l'étranger la direction nationale du
renseignement territorial qui apporte
aussi son son concours la préfecture de
police dans toutes ses composantes et
enfin la direction nationale de la
position frontière qui joue aussi un
rôle au travers du du contrôle que cette
direction exerce à nos
frontières là je vais vous citer
quelques chiffres parce que je pense que
ça illustre
aussi gure du problème auquel on est
confronté
euh on voit que cette mobilisation de la
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
que je décrivait euh c'est traduite par
une augmentation très significative sur
une longue période du nombre des trafics
démantelés et des mises en cause pour
trafic entre 2020 et 2022 entre 2000 et
2022 pardon par exemple pour les on est
passé de 4500 faits de trafic sans usage
en 2000 en 2000 à 16700 en 2022
pour lesffet d'usage revente on est
passé de 14400 à
26600 on est passé de 7600 trafiqu en
mise en cause à
19300 on est passé de 14200 usagers
revendeurs à 16900 et en fait
globalement si on fait un
chiffre si si on résume l'ensemble de
ces chiffres le total des mis en cause
pour infraction à la législation sur les
stupéfiant est passé de 106000 en 2000 à
258000 en 2022 une haose de 143
%. et ce qu'il convient de constater
mais c'est pas dans une forme de
concurrence stupide que j'afficherai
face à vous mais c'est la réalité du
trafic auquel on est confronté c'est ce
sont les services de police qui
constatent environ 80 % de de ces
trafics puisqu'ils sont essentiellement
concentrés dans les zones urbaines Z
urbaines qui sont des zones de
responsabilité de la police nationale
sur le les saisis de stupéfiants pour
aussi vous montrer un peu l'évolution à
laquelle on a été confronté entre 2000
et 2022 pareil pour les saisies de
cannabis herb et résine elles ont
augmenté de 95
%. pour les saisis de cocaïne elles ont
augmenté de plus de 1000
%. pour les saisies d'héroïnes elles ont
progressé de 215 %. et pour la saisie
des avoirs criminels en matière de
stupéfion évidemment au cours des
dernières années elles ont progressé de
136 %. donc on voit là aussi aussi bien
sur les arrestations que sur les cisis
de produits la progression est est
relativement énorme donc quelle est
la quelle est la nature des des moyens
que que la police nationale a engagé
pour faire face à cette réalité et dans
quelle dans quelle dynamique dans quelle
stratégie on a le gouvernement a lancé
en 2019 le plan national de lutte contre
les trafics de stupéfiants qui est
coordonné par l'Office antistupéfiant
qui est un service interministériel qui
pilote et qui coordonne la lutte contre
les TR trafic de stupéfance sur le
territoire national parmi les personnels
qui composent l'oface on a bien sûr des
policiers mais on a aussi des gendarmes
des douaniers un représentant du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
un agent de l'administration
pénitentiaire et six officiers de
liaison étranger ce plan est en cours de
refonte je ne sais pas s'il sera publié
avant l'issue de vos travaux mais
évidemment j'imagine que vous en aurez
connaissance notre objectif au travers
du renouvellement de ce plan c'est de
mettre en œuvre de nouvelles mesures
pour tenir compte des des solution que
j'ai décrite devant vous avec l'objectif
d'améliorer la connaissance des trafics
d'entraver la circulation des produits
stupéfiants et bien sûr de démanteler de
encore du du mieux que nous pouvons les
organisations criminelles qui se livrent
à ce trafic de stupéfiant par ailleurs
leoface est chargé d'un état de la
menace qui est toujours un document très
important qui vous sera évidemment
communiqué au travers des demandes que
vous avez que vous avez formulé quelles
sont les mesures qu'on a mis en œuvre
depuis 2019 chez j'espère que je suis
pas trop long mais je vais aller je vais
aller très vite euh il y a la
cartographie des des points de deal qui
a permis de de comptabiliser les
opérations de démantellement qui étaient
conduites donc au 4e trimestre de
l'année 2020 nous avions 4034 points de
deal qui été
recensé au 2e trimestre de cette année
nous avions 3069 points de deal qui étit
recensé ce qui fait une diminution de
965 en 2022 ce sont 16625 opérations qui
ont été conduites contre ces points de
deal qui ont provoqué un peu plus de
15000 gardes à vue un peu plus de dem000
écrou je vous pas je vous fais grâce des
chiffres de sais de produits stéfiant
mais je noterai quand même que 846 armes
ont été saisies à l'occasion de ces
opérations et plus de 11 millions
d'euros d'avoir criminel un autre
dispositif qui fonctionne bien c'est la
plateforme de de signalement qui permet
sur l'application m sécurité aux
citoyens de signaler de manière anonyme
les faits de trafic qu'ils sont amenés à
constater autour d'eux ou ou près de
chez eux en 2023 pour vous montrer quand
même l'efficacité de ce dispositif la
moyenne mensuelle de signalement reçu
sur la plateforme est de 850 et ce sont
les c'est c'est le vecteur de recueil
d'information le plus utilisé par les
les cross
euh c'est 60 % des
informations recueillies par les cross
donc ce déploiement des cellule de
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants
euh il y en a 104 autant que de
département aussi bien en métropole
qu'en outreem certaines sont permanentes
au regard de l'intensité des trafics
d'autres sont sont temporaires ces cross
en 2022 ont reçu 11214 renseignements
dont près de 5000 ont fait l'objet d'une
note de renseignement et ces notes de
renseignement ont évidemment
entraîner le démarrage de procédur
douanièr ou de procédures judiciaaires
mais là aussi
les chiffres vous seront
communiqués le
rôle de l'ofast est aussi de se
mobiliser dans l'intensification et le
renforcement de la coopération
internationale sans cette coopération
internationale il n'y a pas de lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiant
possible
euh nous réfléchissons à quelques
nouvelles mesures qui seront contenu
dans dans le plan rénové vous
comprendrez que je n'en fasse pas état à
ce stade ce qui nous paraît essentiel en
tout état de cause c'est qu'on puisse
renforcer nos capacités de lutte contre
les cybertrafics dont on voit
l'importance qu'ils ont aujourd'hui et
le développement qu'ils peuvent
connaître je n'oublie pas non plus notre
rôle qui consiste à participer aux
politiques de prévention contre les
conduites addictives on oublie trop
souvent que la question des stupéfiances
c'est aussi aussi un problème de de
santé publique et avec laamdk nous nous
travaillons à à déconstruire les
stéréotypes qui sont véhiculés par par
les trafics de stupéfiants ou les usages
de stupéfiants notamment auprès des plus
jeunes avec
parfois le développement de l'idée que
c'est l'argent facile c'est
l'impunité et une image dans les
quartiers du dealer qui peut
malheureusement être parfois extrêmement
positive il y a quelques possibilités
d'amélioration de nos outils dans la
lutte contre le trafic de de
suppliéfiant
euh notamment pour tout ce qui tourne
autour des techniques spéciales
d'enquête dont on voit bien que pour
pénétrer les trafics les plus structurés
les plus organisés nous avons besoin de
la plus grande des discrétion pour ne
pas dévoiler nos modes d'action auprès
des des trafiquants il y a évidemment un
travail à approfondir pour tout ce qui
touche au des avoirs criminels c'est un
sujet important je pense qu'on peut
encore faire mieux et
davantage on peut peut-être réfléchir
aussi mais je veux dire ça ne relève pas
évidemment de l'administration que de le
proposer mais à
des systèmes qui permettrai de de
renforcer la sévérité et la dureté des
sanctions appliqué aux trafiquants de
stupéfiants et nous pensons aussi que
nous devrions réfléchir face à la masse
d'information dont nous disposons à
propos de ces trafics de
pouvoir avoir accès à un système de
traitement et de croisement de données
qui nous permettrait de comprendre un
peu mieux la manière dont les les
trafics fonctionne une phrase pour
conclure monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur et mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je l'ai
dit nous sommes confrontés à une
difficulté majeur c'est que le le
phénomène est mondial avec des
organisations criminelles qui cherchent
en permanence à contourner les
dispositifs qui sont mise en place par
les États pour les empêcher de nuire
mais ils sont disposés évidemment à à
tout faire notamment en utilisant les la
la violence nous en France je dirais ce
qui m'a le plus frappé au travers des
différents épisodes qui m'ont conduit
dans ma vie professionnel à traiter de
ce sujet du trafic de stupéfiants c'est
que nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui à
desjà ont la possibilité de gagner très
vite beaucoup d'argent et qui n'ont peur
ni de mourir ni de la prison et qui
intègre dans leur avenir l'idée que la
perspective d'aller Auel de 30 ans
alors hasard et pour eu quelque
chose d'un peu sans espoir donc
effectivement ça ça limite capacité
d'agir sur C trafi et
trafiant Monsieur présidentieur
rapporteur merci Monsieur le Directeur
général avant d'ouvrir une une une
batterie de question de nos collègues
peut-être relancer sur la question du du
rapporteur s'agissant de Marseille et
puis peut-être plus plus globalement
dans ce constat assez
sombre malgré une activité intense qui
connaît des des des succès des réussites
on a un peu le sentiment que qu'on est
comme cisif à espérer pouvoir pousser un
peu le rochet est-ce que vous qui avez
une vision longue depuis l'île Marseille
et puis de vos responsabilités sur la
lutte contre les stupéfiant quelles sont
les constantes et quelles sont les
évolutions parce que finalement vous
nous avez parlé de produit on peut
considérer qu'un produit chasse l'autre
on voit aux États-Unis fintanil qui
commence à arriver chez nous mais
qu'est-ce qui dans les dans les la
structuration du marché évolue alors
vous avez parlé du cyber vous avez parlé
de du rajunissement des cadres de ces
trafics et et du coup
peut-être en un ou ou plusieurs mots
quels sont les les les les les les
angles prioritaires parce que le but de
notre mission de commission d'enquête
c'est quand même de trouver aussi
quelques pistes
législatives pour vous aider et
améliorer le la lutte de la société
contre ces trafic don voilà les
constantes sur le temps long les
constantes et puis les principaux points
d'évolution et puis la question du du
rapporteur sur sur Marseille qui est un
peu la même d'une certaine manière
puisque vous y tes passé que les choses
ont changé puis après on passera à des
questions des
collègues si je compare par rapport au
20e siècle période où j'exerce c'est à
Marseille quand les malfaiteurs voulai
s'enrichir ils commettaient des vols à
armé c'était ça le moyen de s'enrichir
quand on était voyou délinquant et
l'activité de stupéfiant était
considérée un peu dans le milieu comme
quelque chose qui n'était pas forcément
très acceptable même si Marseille a
toujours été d'une manière ou d'une
autre un peu la capitale du trafic de
stupéfiant si on remonte à des années
encore plus plus anciennes on voit bien
que les laboratoires de trafic
d'héroïnees était implanté à Marseille
les chimistes étaient marseillais et à
une époque la la DEA la drog Enforcement
Administration avait installer une
antenne une antenne à Marseille pour
lutter contre le le trafic d'héroïne
donc il y a un peu là-bas cette capacité
cette histoire qui qui pèse sans doute
sur sur la ville et sur le territoire
mais progressivement avec cet argent
facile et avec la disponibilité du
produit qui s'est qui s'est amélioré
évidemment
cette
une activité qui s'est répandue partout
partout sur les territoires et à partir
du moment où vous arrivez à une
saturation du marché si vous décidez de
vous étendre le seul moyen de pouvoir le
faire c'est d'éliminer la concurrence et
à partir du moment où vous décidez
d'éliminer la concurrence vous entrez
dans des logiques de vant d'État comme
celle qu'on observe à Marseille entre
certaines familles qui font
que le vivier de cette vantéa est est
inépuisable c'est c'estàdire que on
peut c'est pire que les montigus et les
capulés c'està qu'on sait qu'il y a pas
il y a pas de fin quoi C et que la la la
violence la violence est sans limite et
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes en capacité de
trouver un peu n'importe qui pour
commettre un assassinat pour pour 100000
€ et c'est sans doute aussi lié mais je
vais pas me risquer à sortir du du
périmètre qui est qui qui est le mien
mais aussi sans doute à la à la
sociologie du territoire qui a aussi
considérablement évolué qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas celui que que j'ai connu que
j'ai connu quand quand j'ai exercé donc
aujourd'hui n'importe qui qui veut
s'investir dans le trafic de stupéfiant
a la capacité de se procurer des
quantités des quantités importantes et
là où quand j'étais un policier
opérationnel quand on saisissait 1 kg
d'héroïne ou 1 kil de cocaïne à
Marseille on pensait avoir fait la faire
de l'année aujourd'hui ce sont des
quantités qu'on retrouve à angoulem à
Cholet à Charleville mière et on a même
trouvé à chon surs il y a pas longtemps
une quarantaine de kilos
d'héroïne donc c'est cette capacité
cette disponibilité de la marchandises
et les profits que ça peut que ça peut
générer voilà moi ce qui ce qui me
marque ce qui d'ailleurs je disais au
niveau des vol des voles à armé nous n
avons pratiquement plus sur notre
territoire c'est quelque chose à
part quelques-uns qui peuvent encore
avoir l'adrénaline de vouloir commettre
souvent à l'étranger d'ailleurs en
Suisse ou en Allemagne commettre des
vols à armé contre des transports de
fond merciur général alors ns collègues
s'inscrivent Roger carucci pour
commencer on prend une volée de question
ça vous va euh Franck dersin euh Olivier
cadiic marie-lore finera or voilà qure
Monsieur le Directeur général on
comprend bien que pour nous si je puis
dire nous parlementaires ce que vous
nous demandez sans le demander c'est à
la fois de renforcer les sanctions
contre les trafiquants donc de modifier
probablement les textes mettant en en
jeu l'action judiciaire de faciliter
probablement la saisie des avoirs
criminels de renforcer ça c'est naturel
les moyens du ministère de l'intérieur
ça on le fait depuis des années et on a
l'impression que c'est une course
permanente c'est-à-dire que d'un côté il
y a de plus en plus de trafic de
trafiquant et d'argent facile entre
guillemets lié à ces trafics et de
l'autre côté les pouvoirs publics court
derrière mais ont du mal je dois dire
que quand vous dites vous-même qu'en
France en 2020 c'est 4,2 milliards
dépensé ça doit faire beaucoup d'mules
dans les quartiers est-ce que ça n'est
pas mon opinion personnelle mais
certains disent mais est-ce qu' qu'il
faudrait pas fractionner la lutte contre
la drogue par exemple en légalisant le
cannabis est-ce que vous avez là-dessus
une opinion est-ce que en quoi que ce
soit c'est pas une lutte globale contre
l'ensemble des
trafics monsieur oui ne faudrait-il pas
pour donc lutter efficacement contre le
narcobanditisme simplifier la Procé
pénale afin que les voyou si vous voulez
ne bénéficient pas de vis de forme grâce
à la lourdeur des procédures parce que
j'entends souvent parler de cela on
entend qu'on
relâche souvent des gens pour ce type de
de chos et comme l'a dit le président
nous on a besoin d'éléments pour qu'on
puisse derrière faire voter les les
textes qui qui qui vous aident cuit de
la durée de la garde à vue qui est 96 he
est-ce suffisant pour pouvoir réaliser
tous les actes enquêtes sur les grosses
enquêtes
stup et ne faudrait-il pas doubler je
dirais l'ensemble des enquêtes stup par
une enquête financière afin de saisir un
maximum de biens
enfin ne faudrait-il pas aussi
simplifier la procédure et et et voir
comment on pourrait avoir une une
anonymisation pardon des enquêteurs et
des
magistrats
merci Marie Laure finera or oui finera
Orte
président oui merci de me donner la
parole Monsieur le Directeur général je
suis sénatrice de la Guyane vous avez
évoqué dans votre exposé donc la Guyane
et en ce moment ils ont mis donc un
dispositif de contrôle à 100 % PRS les
aéroports alors la population est
excédée mais les policiers ég éement ils
sont fatigués puce que hier j'ai pris
l'avion pour venir pour rentrer à Paris
et j'ai échangé avec quelques policiers
de la PAF et qui me disait madame la
sénatrice aidez-nous on comprend hein
qu'il faille mettre des moyens pour
endiguer ce fléo parce que chez nous
c'est un fléo et ça touche pas
uniquement les jeunes puisque hier au
départ de de félixboué ils ont empêchai
52 passagers de prendre l'avion et parmi
il y avait une dame qui qui partait en
évacuation sanitaire donc elle en avait
sur le fauteil elle en avait sur elle
donc elle pensait qu'en partant voilà on
sous assistance médicale qu'elle aurait
pas été fouillée et en fait ben voilà
voilà des cas et donc moi je comprends
ce sont des moyens qu'on essaie de
mettre mais je remarque en tout cas le
constat que je fais c'est que ben ça
continue ça continue de plus en plus
l'autre l'autre déplacement que je fais
il y a 82 personnes qui n'ont pas pu
prendre l'avion parce que ben elles
portait ou elles avaient ingéré des des
des ovules et donc
donc ça veut dire que en fait le
contrôle à 100 % on n'arrête pas
puisqu'il y en a quand même les gens
n'ont pas peur ils viennent ils savent
que vous rentrez pas dans l'aérogin si
la police ne vous pose pas les questions
quand vous êtes en face de jeunes qui
viennent en tong et à qui on demande
mais vous allez où je vais à Arcachon
mais si vous conisses pas ils
connaissent même pas des fois ils n'ont
jamais pris l'avion il ils partent pour
la première fois mais le le la pas du
gain des 4000 € qu'on leur a promis
quand il va arriver à à horly euh voilà
les poussent à le faire c'est vrai qu'on
a une grande précarité une grande
pauvreté chez nous mais enfin en tout
cas le moyen les moyens mis en place bah
ne ne permettent pas de ralentir donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire il faut qu'on
trouve une solution parce que c'est pas
possible nous sommes en Amérique du Sud
et et la production de cocaïne elle est
elle est elle est dans le elle est sur
ce territoire donc forcément la Guyane
est un transit pour pouvoir amener euh
la cocaïne en France donc voilà moi je
suis pour hein les moyens je suis pour
le contrôle à 100 % je l'avais dit mais
quand je constate que bah il y a autant
sinon plus les gens vont ils partent il
ils vont quand même et on les arrête on
les empêche de voyager 5 jours euh enfin
il y a un arrêté préfectoral qui est
pris et cetera mais euh moi j'aurais
tellement aimé qu'on trouve une solution
et même euh de manière législative
également comme l'ont rappelé les
collègues il y a des choses à faire
voilà Monsieur le Directeur c'est ce que
je voulais vous poser merci Olivier
kadiic merci monsieur le Président oui
mon intervention va venir
compléter celle de de ma collègue
puisque je reviens là de d'Amérique
latine moi je représente les Français du
monde entier j'étais au Brésil encore la
semaine dernière et donc effectivement
je ne peux que aller dans le sens
puisqu'on sait que de guyan partent
effectivement un certain nombre de mules
dans chaque
avion les Néerlandais ont adopté un
dispositif je crois que lorsqu'ils
saisissent ils arrêtent quelqu'un à
l'arrivée jusqu'à 4 kg de cocaïne ils
détruisent la drogue tout de suite et il
renvoi la personne la mule vers vers les
pays vers le l'origine je crois que ça a
été quelque chose qui qui fonctionne je
voudrais savoir quelle est votre opinion
par rapport au sujet euh je sais aussi
que certains utilisent dans certains
aéroports pour bloquer effectivement
pour détecter euh les trafiquants ils
utilisent le bodys scan et j'ai cru
comprendre que pour des raisons légales
ça n'est pas possible si vous pouviez
nous dire euh ce que vous en pensez pour
que éventuellement on puisse euh faire
évoluer la législation dans ce domaine
euh et puis euh bien évidemment c'est ce
que ce que vient de dire ma collègue est
une vraie préoccupation parce que euh on
si on sait queil y a une cinquantaine de
personnes qui sont qui ont de la drogue
mais que pour vous euh très é une mule
va
nécessiter des policiers va nécessiter
des fonctionnaires au niveau de au
niveau du judiciaire va nécessiter des
médecins pour le temps que on puisse
récupérer la drogue qui est ingérée tout
ça on voit que ça prend du temps vous
avez le temps d'en traiter un certain
nombre mais c'est un petit peu comme
faisaient les Goo auparavant quand il
devait faire TR traverser un troupeau de
beauovin quand dans une rivière qui
avait des Piran on en sacrifiait un donc
les piranas allaient sur le sur le bœuf
en question et tout le troupeau passait
est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
qu'on V un peu cette situation
merci Monsieur sénateur oui c'est une
course permanente sans doute euh mais
c'est une
course dans laquelle on marque des
points euh alors évidemment c'est pas
spectaculaire les chiffres que je
donnais pour l'évolution du nombre de
points de Deal
et sont significatifs pour ça et bon
toute la marchandise qui est récupérée
tous les trafiquants qui sont sortis de
circuit c'est autant de de victoirees et
vous savez moi je souvent je dis j'ai
pas la prétention de dire que nous
travaillons à l'éradication du trafic de
stup dans notre pays ou même dans le
monde on s'aperçoit quand même que dans
les pires dictatures euh je prendrai le
risque de les de les citer mais enfin
comme
alors faudrait pas que mon propos
diplomatiquement so soit mal interprété
mais en Iran ou en Chine
en Russie on voit bien que malgré les
systèmes qui sont en place le trafic de
stupéfiant perdure et la consommation et
l'usage continue donc personne n'est en
capacité aujourd'hui de de promouvoir ou
de dire que l'éadication du trafic de
stupéfiant est possible par
contre ce que je promeuts et ce que je
porte c'est
le l'idée de l'impunité
zéro l'impunité zéro pour les
territoires et l'impunité zéro pour les
personne c'està qu'à un moment ou un
autre il y a un territoire un lieu un
point de Deal un appartement on pu on ne
puisse pas se dire nous on a toujours
échappé à à l'action de la police ou à
l'action de la justice donc partout il
faut qu'on soit en capacité d'agir
d'interpeller et et de et de saisir donc
à la fois pour pour les territoires et
pour les personnes aussi que il y en a
pas dans le dispositif un ou deux qui
puissent dire aux autres regardez moi je
me suis jamais fait attraper par la
police donc ça c'est pour nous quelque
chose de tout à fait euh
important vous avez posé une question
qui évidemment est d'actualité c'est la
question face à ce que certains
considèrent comme de
l'impuissance ce qui n'est de mon point
de vue pas le cas est-ce qu'on doit pas
avoir recours à d'autres systèmes dont
celui de la légalisation du du cannabis
d'abord je je pense que ça serait un
très mauvais signal adresser à
l'ensemble de de ces délincants en
disant bah finalement on a perdu la
partie donc puisquon a perdu la partie
on va faire autre chose et et partout où
on s'est
dirigé vers ce type de fonctionnement ça
n'a réglé aucun problème en fait ça a
même fait sans doute que les aggrav
parce que bon les trafiquants ne
s'installent jamais dans un système
vente légale de cannabis et ils vont à
la recherche d'autres
produits d'autres modes de consommation
d'autres qualités de produit d'autres
prix donc ça sera de toute
façon je pense que ça sera la double
peine c'est-à-dire que on donnera un
signal très négatif et on ne gagnera pas
pour autant la guerre contre la drogue
donc je pense que tous les services qui
traitent de ces sujets là partagent ce
même point de vue monsieur sénateur vous
avez posé une question
essentielle sur la simplification de la
procédure indépendamment de la lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiant les les
policiers revendiquent cette
simplification de la procédure mais ont
le sentiment qu'à chaque fois que on s'y
attaque pardonnez-moi de le dire de
cette façon mais quand les textes
sortent du Sénat ou du enfin du Sénat du
Parlement en général ou du Conseil
constitutionnel on a l'impression que en
fait
certes il y a quelques avancées mais il
y a aussi
euh
euh quelques décisions qui contribue à
complexifier encore la la la procédure
la procédure pénale n il y a puisqu'on
parle des trafic évidemment on me dira
que je ne dois pas commenter une
décision de justice même si elle est
constitutionnelle mais le le fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel est sanctionné
la possibilité d'activer à distance
euh les caméras ou les micros des
téléphones portables est évidemment une
pour nous un un très mauvais signal
envoyé à la lutte contre le crime
organisé et en particulier la lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiant donc
oui tout ce qui pourra permettre mais
vraiment de simplifier la procédure
c'est-à-dire de de faire moins
d'actes purement formel vous savez si si
on double le temps de la garde à vue
mais que dans le même temps on double
les contraintes de formalisme dans la
procédure ça servira pas à grand-chose
j'avais
été reçu
par deux de vos collègues ici au
Sénat sur le projet de loi justice je
crois et on on discutait de de la visite
médicale pendant la garde à vue et de la
possibilité de recourir à la
télémédecine
euh pendant le temps de la garde à vue
et j'avais compris que pour ce qui était
de la première visite médicale il y
avait sous la pression de certains lobby
ou pas d'ailleurs c'est pas je sais que
le Sénat fonctionne pas sous la pression
mais bon la tentation
de d'imposer la visite médicale en
présence d'un médecin la première visite
médicale avec quand même comme
conséquence de beaucoup de territoires
où l'accès au médecins est extrêmement
difficile donc on avait en fait le choix
entre pas de médecin ou ou un médecin
mais si c'est le médecin c'est une
patrouille de police ou de gendarmerie
qui part pendant des heures et qui au
lieu de faire autre chose va faire la
queue aux urgences pour essayer de de
faire examiner le la personne gardée à
vue donc ça
c'estqute pas voilà exactement c'est euh
avec quand même un un paradoxe total
même si c un droit où on commence par
dire aux gens qu'ils ont le droit de se
taire et ensuite on multiplie les actes
de pur formalisme qui font que ça
décourage énormément les enquêteurs de
s'engager sur cette mission de de
l'investigation et ça les les vrais
malfaiteurs les vrais trafiquants
évidemment en exploitent toutes toutes
les les possibilité euh dans le même
ordre d'idée l'anonymisation des
enquêteurs c'est vraiment aussi un sujet
évidemment auquel nous sommes très très
attentif
euh c'est déjà possible euh surous
certaines conditions c'est pas toujours
extrêmement utilisé par par les
enquêteurs et euh il y a un projet du du
gouvernement
de
pouvoir la rendre cette
anonymisation de manière plus général au
deà même des enquêteurs puisqu'on peut
avoir des des policiers qui sont engagés
sur la voie publique qui font l'objet de
de menac ou de représail parce qu'ils
sont connus de la part des individus qui
tiennent des points de Deal ou ou des
des points de de
stupéfiant même la sénatrice sur sur la
Guyane je
je suis heureux de vous entendre dire
que 52 passagers ont été empêchés hier
effectivement c'est une une méthode que
le ministre d' l'intérieur des outrmèes
a souhaité mettre en œuvre c'est
d'empêcher le départ
des des mules c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle avec une stratégie des
trafiquants qui est de dire avant que ce
système
n'existe sur un vol on on met 40 mules
on sait que la douane et la police n La
capité d'en traiter aller au maximum que
5 ou si donc en fait c'est c'est la part
qu'on accepte de perdre pour que 35
réussissent à arriver à
destination donc la la stratégie
effectivement c'est c'est pénible pour
les forces mais on y a
aussi mis mis les moyens mais je pense
que que l'enjeu est est déterminant à la
fois pour empêcher que cette cocaïne
arrive dans l'Hexagone mais aussi pour
décourager ces pauvres gens qui sont les
victimes les trafiquants les premières
victimes de ces trafiquants de se
retrouver embarqués dans un système qui
va les conduire s'ils sont arrêtés à
être à être condamné donc vous me dites
il faut trouver une solution euh la
solution ça serait
de de faire diminuer la la production de
de cocaïne en Amérique du Sud je crains
que on emprennent pas le le chemin avec
d'autres pays qui jusqu'àalors n'étaient
pas des gros producteurs et qui le qui
le devienne j'ai tendance à penser
puisque vous citiez l'exemple je crois
c'est vous monsieur sénateur de ce qui
se passe de ce qui s'est passé au
Pays-Bas c'est que au bout d'un moment
on finisse par décourager ces candidats
au départ vers l'hexagone et que
malheureusement les trafiquants se
tournent vers d'autres moyens de passage
que de mais je sais que évidemment
là-bas ça ça touche la
population la plus en difficulté et qui
peut au travers d'un passage réussi
aussi avoir l'espoir de démarrer une
nouvelle vie au travers du de du revenu
que que procure que procure ce voyage et
ce que vous décrivez du profil des
individus qui se présentent à
l'embarquement enfin nous on le constate
pour avoir assisté à une procédure
d'embarquement à Cayenne on voit bien il
y en a qui qui sont incapables de
répondre à la première des questions qui
ont juste un sac plastique pour faire le
voyage voilà et qui porte sur eux les 2
3 4 kg de cocaïne pour arriver à
destination
euh alors vous avez monsieur sénateur
parlé de du body sccan la difficulté à
laquelle on est confronté c'est la
présence d'un médecin en fait pour
procéder à ce qui ça apparente à un
examen médical et là aussi c'est
toujours pareil la disponibilité des des
médecins éant é en scalé ça ça rend les
choses ça rend les choses extrêmement
compliquées et on voit bien d'ailleurs
euh pour continuer sur ce que vous
évoquiez tous les deux sur ces systèmes
on voit bien qu'on commence à assister à
un déport
de de ces candidats au départ vers
l'Hexagone c'està-dire au lieu de
prendre le vol direct Cayenne Paris Orly
en fait ils font Cayenne la geloupe ou
la Martinique pour rebondir et espérer
moins attirer l'attention en venant de
donc les avions n'étant pas contrôlé de
manière aussi systématique à destination
de euh des Antilles euh de de pouvoir
contourner le le bouclier qui qui est
mis en place donc c'est difficile mais
on n pas d'autre choix que que le faire
on a eu aussi une triste histoire à à
l'aéroport de de Cayenne avec des des
jeunes policiers aux frontières qui
malheureusement je sais pas vous avez
sans doute entendu parler de cette
affaire qui séit rendu complice
trafiquant considérant que les blocages
qui existaient le seul moyen de
contourner c'est là où je disais que la
corruption fait parfois son œuvre de
manière très négative ben s'appuyer sur
celles et ceux qui sont chargés de faire
respecter les addiction pour les
contourner de la manière la plus dab
enfin la la plus habile possible
voilà pour leage d'ut
serv d'autes pays
utilisent
ça dépasse ma compétence monsieur
sénateur Monsieur le Directeur général
on on prétend que de nouvelles routes
vous avez fait allusion à des routes
d'approvisionnement de l'Europe en
différentes
substances on prétend que depuis que le
venezuelois de l'après Maduro est devenu
le royaume des mol iranien de nouvelles
routes se sont ouvertes est-ce qu'il
faut apporter du crédit à cette
affirmation là
je ne suis pas en capacité de vous
répondre sur le lien avec l'Iran entre
l'Iran et le Venezuela mais peut-être
que la chef de l'ofaste aura des
éléments de réponse à ce
propos monsieur le rapporteur et bien
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général pour
cette présentation globale qui va sans
doute appeler à d'autres entretiens moi
j'ai noté une
chose vous avez dans les propositions
que vous avez faites parlé de technique
spécial d'enquête est-ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser
[Musique]
ce à quoi vous faites allusion quand
vous parlez de ces techniques spéciales
et puis vous avez mentionné la question
des saisies nous savons aujourd'hui que
la confiscation des avoirs est une des
méthodes les plus efficaces et quelles
sont selon vous les pistes
d'amélioration de ces procédures de
saisie de manière général je pense que
ça appellera des communication écrite
pour pour ce qui est des techniques
spéciales d'enquête je pensais à une
technique qui est en particulier très
utile et et très efficace même
si le recours a tendance plutôt à
baisser c'est celui de de
l'infiltration mais pour la rendre
efficace évidemment il faut que les
éléments relatifs à C infiltration ne
soient pas connus des des
malfaiteurs et donc l'idée c'est serait
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon un dossier coffre il s'agit pas
de faire ça à l'insu de évidemment de
l'autorité judiciaire ou de la procédure
judiciaire mais que les éléments
relatifs à cette procédure
d'infiltration soit contenu dans un
dossier qui ne serait pas parti à la
procédure
auquel éventuellement le procureur de la
République ou le président du tribunal
pourrait avoir accès en cas de de
problème mais qui ne permettrait pas
au aux personnes mises en cause d'avoir
accès à la fois aux éléments d'identité
ou aux éléments qui ont pu être mis en
œuvre
pour permettre ou ou
favoriser cette infiltration le COF
pourrait être ouvert que par les
magistrats c'est c'est une propos en cas
de problèm ou de difficultés identifié
qui
ou de contestation de la
[Musique]
part de la partie mise en
cause en tout cas qui permettrait de
garantir la la confidentialité de
l'opération qui a été conduite
voouà pour ce qui est
de des avoirs euh criminels
euh je pense qu'effectivement on aura
peut-être l'occasion où où les
spécialistes de ces procédures de
confiscation et de saisie des avoirs
pourront peut-être en parler beaucoup
mieux que moi euh ça serait peut-être de
de rendre obligatoire euh
dans certaines circonstances la
confiscation de des biens de la personne
qui qui est mise en cause pour le moment
il n'y a rien il n'y a rien
d'obligatoire ça serait
aussi
d'étudier la la possibilité de de
procéder à des saisies
conservatoires qui peuvent concerner des
biens d'individus qui sont en fuite à
l'étranger
[Musique]
euh voilà c'était les de deux des pistes
auxquelles auxquelles nous
pensions président ça va est-ce
que à ce stade
euh peut-être juste avant de vous
libérer complètement
euh sur ce dernier sujet comment
analysez-vous la la la place prise par
l'administration des douanes euh dans la
lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants
parce que il y a un lien direct avec ce
que vous avez
indiqué alors je me garderai bien de
d'apprécier mais je je pense que leur
place est nécessaire malheureusement euh
la réalité du trafic dans notre pays
montre que même en se
répartissant intelligemment et
efficacement le travail on n vient pas à
bout donc je pense que tout le monde a a
son rôle à sa place police gendarmerie
douane qui évidemment exerce plutôt son
activité à destination des saisim mais
enfin ils arrêtent aussi aussi des gens
la place de la Marine nationale qui est
importante qui procède à des à
raisonnements qui sont aussi dans le
cadre de la lutte contre le trafic
absolument intéressant je crois que
vraiment tout le monde tout le monde a a
sa place et il y a certainement pas de
place pour des luttes ou des querelles
d'influence ou d'intérêt entre les
services qui sont en charge de la lutte
contre le trafic de stupéfiant estce que
simplement tout à l'heure vous avez dit
et on a senti que ça marchait pas aussi
bien que vous le vouliez quand vous
parliez justement pour rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit le président vous avez parlé de
traitement et de croisement des données
donc est-ce çaà dire justement qu'entre
les différents services il y a encore là
des manquements sans accuser personne
évidemment non monsieur le sénateur non
c'est vraiment c'est face à la masse des
données qui sont aujourd'hui disponibles
je pense qu'on aurait intérêt à pouvoir
disposer de ce que nous propose
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
ou ou l'Internet
pour mixer l'ensemble de ces données et
essayer d'en retirer évidemment des
éléments d'information intéressants
c'estàd qu'on puisse aussi se servir de
données qui existent dans un cadre
judiciaire de données qui existent dans
un cadre administratif de données qui
dépendent de celles qui sont concentré à
l'ofast mais aussi dans d'autres
administrations comme à Tracfin ou
ailleurs de faire en sorte Queau travers
de système automatisé on soit en
capacité
peut-être d'avoir des informations qui
n'apparaissent pas au premier coup d'œil
voilà pour cette première audition à
suivre tout de suite sur le même thème
l'audition cette fois de Stéphanie
charbonniier chef de l'Office
antistupéfiant un organisme créé en 2019
par celui qui était à l'époque ministre
de l'Intérieur Christophe
Castaner avant de avant de démarrer donc
vous présenter les personnes les
personnes qui m'accompagne mon adjoint
Christian Christian doroini également
contrôleur général mais euh magistrat de
l'ordre judiciaire détaché dans un
emploi de contrôleur général ce qui est
une un positionnement assez peu assez
peu classique au sein au sein du
ministère de l'Intérieur madame Sophie
Étienne qui est commandant divisionnaire
et et qui est chargé de la coordination
et de la synthèse au sein de l'OFAS et
qui est accompagné également de Monsieur
Hugo Darbois qui est un de ses
collaborateurs et donc qui participe
évidemment à la préparation de ces de
ces ces exercices euh un propos
liminaire un propos liminaire mesdames
et messieurs mon intervention s'inscrit
bien évidemment en complément de celle
du directeur général qui est intervenue
en en tout début d'après-midi et je
souhaita je souhaitais vraiment à titre
liminaire vous communiquez non pas des
chiffres pour vous
assiner une litanie de chiffres mais
bien reposer les choses et le trafic de
stupéfiant puisque c'est le c'est la
question dans un contexte dans un
contexte un petit peu plus global et
quelques chiffres clés me semble me
semble absolument nécessaire le trafic
de stupéfiant le directeur général l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est le premier
marché criminel au monde il représente
un chiffre d'affaires évalué en France à
3 milliards d'euros 30 milliards d'euros
pour pour l'Europe on estime aujourd'hui
à 21000 le nombre d'emplois temps plein
générés par les trafics de stupéfiants
et à 240000 le nombre de personnes qui
en France vivent directement ou
indirectement de ces trafics en 10ant
les saisies de cocaïne on ont été
multiplié par 5 avec presque 28 tonnes
saisies en 2022 dont 75 % sur sur le
vecteur maritime et puis les saisies de
cannabis quant à elle ont été multiplié
par 2 avec 128 tonnes saisies en
2022 ce sont 111 millions d'avoirs
criminels qui ont été saisis en matière
d'infraction à la législation sur les
stupéfiants soit 13 % du total des
avoirs criminels saisis C ces saisis ont
été multipliés par 2 en 10 ans alors il
faut mettre en regard de ces chiffres
ceux de la production 2300 tonnes de
cocaïne produite en 2021 soit une
multiplication par 2 en 10 ans pour
mémoire les trois pays producteurs sont
la Colombie la Bolivie et le Pérou ceux
des saisis des ports de nos ports
voisins des ports voisins à ceux de la
France ceux d'enverse et de Rotterdam
sont les plus emblématiques avec
respectivement 110 tonnes et 50 tonnes
saisies en 2022 dans chacun de ces dans
chacun de ses ports les chiffres encore
de la consommation en France 5 millions
de consommateurs 5 millions d'usagers
euh dont 1,2 million d'usagers
régulierers de cannabis et 600000
usagers annuels de
cocaïne ceux des violences criminelles
75 règlements de compte entre
malfaiteurs depuis le début de l'année
2023 en sachant que euh entre 80 et 90 %
de ces règlements de compte sont liés au
trafic de stupéfiants je n'y reviens pas
le directeur général l'a développé tout
à l'heure dernier chiffre celui des
saisis d'armes en augmentation de 10 %
en 2022 avec plus de 8000 armes saisies
et là encore une proportion 25 % des
armes saisies le son à l'occasion
d'enquête pour trafic de stupéfiants
alors j'articulerai mon propos en en
quatre quatre quatre points le premier
qui est celui de la menace en rebalayant
rapidement quelques points qui me
semblent essentiel sur sur cet état de
la menace la deuxième partie sur la Rost
qui est apportée euh à ce face à cette
menace un bilan de la politique publique
mise en œuvre depuis depuis 2000 depuis
2019 et puis bien sûr des perspectives
puisque c'est ça qui qui qui nous
intéresse alors l'état de la menace en
matière de trafic de stupéfiants en
France et en Europe puisque je crois
qu'on peut pas regarder la France juste
à travers nos frontières il faut qu'on
ait un regard beaucoup plus global et
cette menace est un niveau
historiquement élevé elle s'illustre à
travers trois constats le premier de ces
constats les produits stupéfiants sont
présents en quantité importante sur le
territoire national et européen la
France est au carrefour des trafics en
raison de son positionnement
géographique elle est bien s on est bien
sûr à proximité des zones de production
des pays producteurs nous sommes
également une zone de rebond pour pour
certains trafics je pense notamment à la
zone
antiguyane globalement aujourd'hui en
France aucun territoire n'est épargné
par les
trafics le sujet majeur de préoccupation
aujourd'hui est celui de de la cocaïne
ça a été largement largement abordé par
le directeur général ce n'est pas là
encore une préoccupation qui est
purement française c'est une
préoccupation qui est européenne alors
dans un contexte d'intensification du
trafic transatlantique la cocaïne arrive
massivement dans l'Union européenne par
les ports principalement les ports
d'Europe du Nord ce que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure en vous donnant des chiffres
extrêmement significatif donc envers et
au Rotterdam à titre de comparaison au
Havre cette année ce en 2022 pardon ce
sont un peu plus de 11 tonnes qui ont
été qui ont été saisies par par les
services principalement de de la
douane alors la France est à la fois une
zone de rebond donc zone antiguyane et
une porte d'entrée par ces ports et ses
aéroports cet engouement pour la cocaïne
est bien sûr lié au niveau de
consommation en France 600000 usagers
annuels je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
mais c'est également lié à un facteur
économique extrêmement important et la
rentabilité de ce produit pour les
organisations
criminelles juste pour illustrer cela
aujourd'hui 1 kil de cocaïne en France
hexagonale s'achète entre 28000 et 30000
€ donc prix au kilo il est revendu au
gram entre 65 € et et 70
€. alors bien sûr les organisations
criminelles sont opportunistes et elles
recherchent du profit c'est leur c'est
leur raison d'être euh donc voilà sur le
le le produit sur la cocaïne ce que ce
que je souhaitais vous dire l'héroïne
redevient un sujet d'attention puisque
les saisies d'héroïn en France ont
augmenté ces dernières années
particulièrement 2022 avec un peu plus
d'une tonne 4 de de saisis c'est un
produit qui est moins consommé mais qui
reste mais qui reste présent sur le
marché et pour lequel on doit avoir une
attention particulière notamment en
raison de la situation en Afghanistan et
puis avec la route des Balcans qui est
la route traditionnelle de euh de de
d'importation de ce produit aujourd'hui
les consommateurs se tournent de plus en
plus vers les drogues de
synthèse ce qu'on appelle les produits
de synthèse avec les opioïdes de
synthèse les cannabinoïdes de synthèse
produits qui présentent des taux de
toxicité extrêmement élevé puisqu'on le
voit également dans les études et
notamment de l'OFDT ou même de l'OEDT au
niveau européen les consommateurs sont à
la recherche de produits aux effets de
plus en plus forts on recense
aujourd'hui en France 365 nouveaux
produits de synthèse
différents euh petit petit focus
toutefois euh puisque tout à l'heure
dans une des questions vous avez évoqué
le fintanil la France n'est aujourd'hui
pas touchée par le fantanil comme les
États-Unis peuvent l'être néanmoins ça
reste un sujet d'attention vraiment très
très important et notamment en terme
sanitaire puisque on sait les dégâts que
que cause le fintanil aux
États-Unis on constate donc l'émergence
de nouveaux marchés et des organisations
criminelles qui s'adaptent et se
diversifi en permanence les trafiquants
sont généralement polyproduits on a eu
des trafiquants qui sont passés de la
résine de cannabis ou de l'herbe de
cannabis à la cocaïne avec un taux de
rentabilité comme je vous l'indiquais un
peu plus haut beaucoup plus élevé les
trafiqu en France sont à la fois le fait
d'organisation criminell français et de
groupes criminels étrangers implantés en
en France je crois qu'il faut vraiment
avoir à l'esprit qu'on est face à des
organisations criminelles qui sont
décloisonnées qui sont opportunistes et
qui qui recherchent les moyens de de
travailler ensemble et les moyens de
s'associer et c'est souvent le cas avec
des des rencontres qui parfois ont lieu
à
l'étranger les organisations criminelles
tentent en toutes circonstance de
déjouer les contrôles on le constate
avec l'émergence de laboratoire sur le
territoire européen alors avec des
démantellements qui ont eu lieu
notamment en
Espagne peu de cas pour l'instant
identifiés en France mais des points
d'attention sur du produits importés et
à transformer avec la Colombie qui
exporte également ces chimistes donc ça
ce sont des points d'attention
particulier et puis ce phénomène de
laboratoire il faut l'avoir à l'esprit
pour tout ce qui est tout ce qui tourne
autour des drogues de synthèse puisque
on le sait au Pays-Bas ou en Belgique
les produits sont transformés sur sur le
territoire deuxème moyen de tournement
des des contrôles le phénomène des
dropof qu'on observe également depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois avec des
transbordements en mer avec de la
cocaïne qui vient s'échouer sur sur les
côtes sur les côtes françaises alors
plutôt manche mer du Nord mais mais
également en
Atlantique donc là
encore c'est une adaptation des
organisations criminelles face au
renforcement des contrôles qui ont été
opérés dans les ports au niveau français
bien sûr mais aussi au niveau européen
EUR puisqu'il y a eu un
travail en coalition avec nos
partenaires européens pour renforcer ces
contrôles dans les ports le deuxème
constat dans cette dans cet état de la
menace les violences criminelles en lien
avec les trafics de stupéfiants sont en
augmentation très significative en
France le directeur général l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure les rivalités de
territoire les concurrences entre
organisations criminelles conduisent
aussi au développement des violences
criminelles qui sont inhérentes à ces
trafics on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans
dans ma présentation sur les chiffres
l'augmentation des armes saisies conduit
inévitablement à une augmentation des
violences alors qu'endon par violence
criminelle ce sont bien sûr les
règlements de compte les h les homicides
volontaires les tentatives d'homicide et
aussi les enlèvement séquestration qu'il
ne faut pas qu'il ne faut pas oublier
dans cette dans cette comptabilisation
les auteurs et les victimes de ces
violences criminelles sont aujourd'hui
de plus en plus jeunes on parle
notamment des petites mains des trafics
mais ces violences peuvent aussi toucher
des victimes collatérales sans aucun
lien avec les trafics on a eu des
événements extrêmement malheureux en
France l'été dernier et puis le weekend
dernier à à
Dijon alors ces violences criminelles
sont généralement soustraité à des
équipes mandatées pour agir recruter
généralement sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment je pense à des phénomènes de
recrutement de tuur à gage à travers les
à travers les réseaux sociaux trème
constat la
corruption le phénomène de la corruption
est de plus en plus révélé et ça ver
être un véritable outil des trafics de
stupéfiants mais j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure c'est un outil plus globalement
de la criminalité organisée puisque de
toute façon les trafics de stupéfiants s
s sont compris dans un ensemble plus
large que celui de la criminalité
organisée sans la corruption qu'elle
soit publique ou privée les trafics ne
prospèrent pas ça peut toucher bien
évidemment des personnels dans les ports
et les aéroports qui vont faciliter le
passage de la marchandise ou le ou ou la
sortie du produit de d'un port ou d'un
d'un aéroport ça peut toucher des agents
publics des policiers des gendarmes des
douaniers des greffiers aucune aucune
profession n'est épargnée dès lors que
vous avez
des des des trafiquants qui offrent des
sommes d'argent extrêmement conséquentes
vous pourrez avoir à un moment donné des
personnels qui qui vont répondre à
l'appel à l'appel de de ces sirènes
criminelles al alors face à cette menace
la France a adapté il y a presque 4 ans
son dispositif de lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants notamment en
favorisant l'approche globale alors la
première étape passait par une meilleure
coordination des acteurs et une
structuration du
dispositif le DGPN vous l'a vous l'a dit
beaucoup d'acteurs luttent contre les
trafics au sein de la police nationale
au sein du ministère de l'Intérieur et
des outrem au sein du ministère de
l'économie et des finances vous
entendiez la directrice générale des
douanes au sein du ministère de la
justice également il y a 4 ans c'est le
besoin de coordination de ces acteurs
qui a été pointé c'est l'ambition du
plan national de lutte contre les
stupéfiant du 17 septembre 2019 cette
politique publique avait besoin d'un
acteur central pour la porter alors sur
le modèle du chef de file en matière de
lutte contre la la la le terrorisme qui
est la DGSI l'ofast toute proportion
gardée puisque la DGSI est une direction
générale et et euh et compte un nombre
de de de personnel beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus important donc l'OFAS
c'est le chef de fil de la lutte contre
contre les trafics de stupéfiants fruit
d'une réforme entrée en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2020 l'ofast c'est un service à
compéten nationale un SCN rattaché à la
Direction national de la police
judiciaire la dnpj et bien sûr la DGPN
l'OFAS dispose une structure centrale
220 220 personnels dont la composition
est très interministérielle je vous
présentais mon adjoint tout à l'heure
donc magistrat de l'ordre judiciaire
détaché dans dans un emploi de
contrôleur général c'est aussi bien sûr
la police la gendarmerie la doit euh le
renseignement pénitentiaire parce que
quand on parle de la justice c'est vrai
qu'on parle on pense tout de suite à mon
adjoint mais il y a également le
renseignement pénitentiaire et ça c'est
un point clé pour pour
l'ofast la DG FIP puisque on parlera du
volet financier des des trafics et il
est très important de pouvoir travailler
avec les services de la DG FIB sur ces
sujetsl bien sûr des personnels
administratifs et des contractuels
j'insiste sur les contractuels puisque
nous avons besoin aussi de compétences
spécifiques dans ce type de structure en
terme d'analyse en terme de coopération
internationale et de connaissance des
mécanisme et donc il est très très
important de pouvoir avoir recours à ces
personnels alors l'idée à l'époque était
de recouper enfin il y a 4 ans était de
regrouper sous une même autorité des
compétences des savoir-faire qui jusqu'à
présent relevaient de plusieurs
administrations au niveau territorial
l'oface compte 24 implantations
territoriales 14 antennes et 10
détachements en hexagone et en outreem
euh mobilisant un peu plus de 550
personnels nous avons déployé également
104 cellules de renseignement
opérationnels sur les stupéfiant les
cross une dans chaque département
regroupant au niveau des territoires là
aussi policiers gendarmes et douaniers
avec pour objectif de décloisonner le
partage de de l'information le le le
croisement du renseignement l'auace
centrale est organisée en trois pôles je
ne vais pas vous les détailler
simplement euh vous les les résumer en
en en trois mots donc trois grandes
missions comprendre cibler agir les
trois pôles de l'ofast c'est le pôle
stratégie c'est le pôle renseignement et
c'est le pôle opérationnel le pôle
stratégie c'est la connaissance des
trafics quelle est la menace à laquelle
on fait face quelle analyse on produit
autour de cette menace quelle stratégie
on déploie en terme de coopération
international c'est extrêmement
important de pouvoir le euh le le le
l'organiser au niveau au niveau central
le renseignement c'est l'une des
avancées majeures de la création de
l'OFAS c'est le développement des
missions de renseignement de ce service
à compétenence nationale l'ofast est un
service de renseignement du second
cercle comme nombre de services de la
dnpj et ça c'est très très important
dans le cadre des des perspectives
notamment à développer la mission
opérationnelle elle est beaucoup plus
classique ce sont la c'est la conduite
bien sûr d'enquête judiciaire s sous
l'autorité des magistrats nous
travaillons principalement avec lesgirs
et euh au premier rang desquels bien sûr
je place la junalco juridiction
spécialisée euh pour travailler sur le
tout à fait le haut de du spectre et le
les les têtes de fil du des
trafic alors après avoir mis en place
les structures la seconde étape
nécessitait de repenser les méthodes
également développer la mission de
renseignement j'en parlais à l'instant
et favoriser l'approche globale d'abord
développer la mission renseignement la
particularité de l'auface comme je vous
l'indiquais c'est d'avoir la double
casquette service de police judiciaire
et service de renseignement du second
cercle l'ofast exerce son rôle de
coordination avec les acteurs du monde
du renseignement il s'agit d'actionner
de nouveaux capteurs de renseignement
avec pour objectif l'entrave l'entrave
du produit l'entrave des individus
l'entrave des organisations criminelles
l'offace est également un acteur de la
de la doctrine du renseignement criminel
de
2021 nos activités dans ce dans ce cadre
sont couvertes par le secret de la
défense nationale et donc je je ne
développerai pas plus avant aujourd'hui
cette ce sujet d'une manière générale il
s'agit de multiplier les capteurs au
plus près des territoires avec les cross
jusqu'à l'internation national nous
avons des
dispositifs qui fonctionnent et qui sont
uniques les unités permanentes de
renseignement en Espagne et en Caraïbes
ce qui nous permet de de de projeter des
des effectifs de l'faste sur ces zones
et puis une équipe dédiée en Colombie
qui est pilotée par notre attaché de
sécurité intérieure en poste en Colombie
et qui là aussi permet de faciliter les
liens et de conduire des enquêtes avec
les autorités colombiennes alors que
signifie favoriser l'approche globale
l'approche globale impose de ne pas
limiter l'action des services à la seule
interception des flux et je pense que
quand on on parle de lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants on ne peut pas
effectivement se contenter de saisir du
produit on le sait ce n'est pas l'effet
attendu ça permet de sortir du marché un
certain nombre
de une des quantités non non
négligeablees de produits mais ce n'est
pas suffisant pour démanteler en en
profondeur les organisations les
organisations criminelles donc pour les
démentanteler ces organisations
criminelles
euh on doit définir une stratégie autour
des cies d'intérêts prioritaires on on a
défin une une stratégie autour des cipes
d'intérêts prioritaires les identifier
et les entraver donc où qu'elles soi en
France comme à l'étranger nous avons eu
plusieurs plusieurs réussites
significatives depuis depuis la mise en
place de l'offast avec 22 22 Cies
d'intérêts prioritaires qui ont été qui
ont été interceptés euh notre rôle est
aussi d' analyser les violences
criminelles l'approche l'approche
globale c'est ça c'est d'analyser
violences criminelles en lien avec les
trafics de stupéfiants les enlèvements
les séquestrations les homicides et les
tentatives d'homicide et leur lien avec
les trafics et puis enfin bien sûr
l'approche globale c'est lutter contre
les flux financiers liés au trafic de
stupéfiants le blanchiment alors la
corruption on n'est pas forcément sur du
flux financier à proprement à proprement
parler même si ils en génèrent
inévitablement et puis bien sûr le
dernier volet c'est celui de la saisie
des avoirs criminels l'approche globale
nécessite enfin et aussi de prendre en
compte la dimension internationale des
trafics au plan opérationnel mais
également au plan stratégique avec la
définition de priorités stratégique je
vous le disais en introduction cette
coopération elle est à la fois
bilatérale et multilatérale
multilatérale j'ai à l'esprit bien
évidemment les liens que nous avons avec
Europol qui sont extrêmement
forts à la fois en participant au cycle
politique d'Europol et puis à toutes les
task forces opérationnelles piloté par
par par l'agence européenne et qui
concerne qui concerne bien sûr la
France Quel bilan tiré de cette
politique publique mise en œuvre depuis
euh depuis 4 ans le plan national de
lutte contre les trafics de stupéfiants
à 4 ans si il avait il comportait 6 axes
et 55 mesures dont un grand nombre a
déjà été a déjà été mis en œuvre le plan
de 2019 a permis la mise en place des
structures notamment l'ofast son réseau
territorial le réseau des cellules de
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants les cross des outils ont été
créés cartofaste la cartographie la
cartographie des points de Deal le
directeur général en a parlé le fichier
des objectifs qui permet aussi de faire
de la déconfliction avec nos services
partenaires notamment les services les
services de la douane les services de la
gendarmerie la mise en place du portail
de signalement qui permet à tout
particulier de pouvoir signaler un
trafic y compris de manière anonyme pour
préserver son identité euh la doctr une
doctrine a été posée permettant à chaque
acteur de connaître son positionnement
et puis une feuille de route
internationale a été établie et mise à
jour annuellement le deuxième temps de
cette politique publique est de toujours
mobiliser pardon davantage d'acteurs en
interministériel à tous les niveaux au
plus près des territoires pour prendre
en compte la réalité des trafics qui
pourrissent la vie des habitants jusqu'à
l'international donc avec la coopération
internationale bien sûr avec les zones
de production le renseignement maritime
qui est un élément central en matière de
lutte contre les trafics de stupéfiants
et puis l'action européenne qui est
conduite qui est conduite dans les ports
afin de maintenir une dynamique la
refondte de ce plan c'est avéré
indispensable le plan national remagné
et qui est en cours de validation reste
guidé par les mêmes impératifs d'origine
beaucoup d'interministérialité et
s'appuie bien sûr sur l'état de la
menace qui est élaboré par l'ofaste et
qui sortira également vous avvez une
première édition de cet état de la
menace en 2021 et la version 2023 est
est sur sur le point de sur le point de
de paraître également résolument
interministériel ce futur plan fédère
l'ensemble des administrations et des
forces compétentes en la matière il
regroupe de nouveaux acteurs que l'on
compte aujourd'hui que l'on comptera
parmi les les contributeurs bien sûr des
services de renseignement mais mais je
je ne vais pas plus avant le secrétariat
le secrétariat général de la mer et la
mission nationale de de contrôle des
précurseurs chimiques puisque quand on
parle de drogue de synthèse il est
extrêmement important de pouvoir
s'intéresser à la composition de ces
drogues de synthèse cette cette feuille
de route rénovée met l'accent sur la la
criminalité connexe au trafic de
stupéfiants les violences criminelles la
corruption et le volet financier des des
trafics avec bien sûr une dimension
internationale extrêmement poussée euh
le point sur lequel je souhaite insister
c'est aussi la nécessité que cette
politique publique s'inscrient dans des
politiques publiques euh également
beaucoup plus larges euh la dimension
santé publique la dimension sanitaire
que le
DGPN a exprimé tout à l'heure le volet
préventif tout ça est impératif pour
lutter contre lutter contre les trafics
et les prévenir puisque et ça c'est le
rôle de la mil des cas puisque le le le
ministère de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes ne peut pas être le seul acteur en
matière en matière de
stupéfiant dernier point celui des
perspectives et j'en aurais j'en aurais
fini avec mon propos introductif
beaucoup de défis à relever encore même
si le plan à 4 ans je crois qu'il faut
être il faut être
extrêmement extrêmement humble à la fois
lucide et humble face à la menace à
laquelle à laquelle on fait
face les défis s'inscrivent dans un
cadre plus global que celui des trafics
de stupéfiants bien c'est mais bien
celui de la criminalité organisée dont
la direction nationale de la police
judiciaire est l'acteur majeur alors
première catégorie de défis des défis
numériques bien sûr avec les réseaux
sociaux qui servent à la fois de vitrine
pour le commerce de la drogue mais aussi
des vecteurs de communication pour pour
les organisations criminelles pour les
trafiquants on recrute aujourd'hui de la
main d'œuvre sur les réseaux sociaux et
je pense que ce point là est est
extrêmement important euh même si nous
avons développé les investigations sur
les réseaux sociaux je pense que il faut
encore aller au-delà de ce qui a de ce
qui a été mis en en place deuxème
catégorie de défis des défis
technologiques
le directeur général tout à l'heure a
parlé euh de des cryptoonnaaies des
cryptoactifs le blanchiment à travers
ces à travers ses outils doit être au
cœur de nos préoccupations on doit aussi
faire évoluer euh nos modes de travail
aujourd'hui c'est c'est ces avoirs là
sont sais sont saisissables et sont
saisis par par les services les
messageries chiffrées euh on a tous en
tête deux noms de messagerie chiffré qui
ont qui ont donné lieu à un important
travail de la France c'est encrechat et
Sky occc ce sont des messageries
utilisées par les groupes criminels
quasiment exclusivement utilisé par les
groupes criminels et notre rôle c'est
d'être toujours euh en avance de phase
et d'essayer de d'être positionné sur le
nouvel outil utilisé par les
organisations criminelles notre objectif
c'est aussi de lutter contre les
contremesures qui sont posées par par
les les organisations criminelles euh
une cargaison de cocaïne aujourd'hui
elle est piégée elle a des balises
posées par les organisations criminelles
qui veulent savoir euh où se situe où se
situe leurs produits euh y compris quand
euh il est dans un container en pleine
mer et qui fait une traversée
transatlantique voilà pour ces échanges
que vous pouvez évidemment euh revoir en
replay ou sur notre plateforme
www.publicsenat.fr excellente journée à
[Musique]
tous